hallo leute diese woche begrüßen wir
euch aus norwegen hier sind wir eine
woche und besuchen verschiedene schulen
und heute haben wir einfach frei und
machen einen kleinen haus zurück wie ihr
wisst immer wenn wir mittel zeit haben
uns dem vikarie antwortet auf und jetzt
beantworten wir wieder eure zuschauer
feuern ist das nicht schön hier eine
schöne insel mit ferienhäusern gefangen
haben mit euren fragen punkt schreibt
auch unser video at the german bakery
und nach circa sieben jahren bekommt
kari die antwort auf die frage die ihn
gefragt hat warum heißt dass amerikaner
amd ziemlicher hammer
denn das ist krass was du doch mal
bronze ist also schon sagen du bist
unser zuschauer des jahres jetzt schon
weil du einfach gewusst hat dass ich vor
sieben jahren in einem video gefragt
habe warum das amerikaner halten
du hast du das einfach gemerkt und das
wussten nicht mal wie ich habe gestern
laut gelacht als ich dazu erstmal
gewesen hat und jetzt auch und sie wird
sicherlich auch machen
danke für diese hinweis wer hat
beschreibt ein ono ist etwas untypisch
war der zehnte sieg in whistler in das
video enthält so anders peter das hängst
das haben sehr viele leute geschrieben
kommt man da wunderschöne hindernis bis
die nicht schön
also viele leute angeschrieben in
unserem video war der bäckerei da haben
wir so komisch langsam gesprochen das
stimmt wenn wir wollten eigentlich ein
super easy german video machen also
einen langsamen video deshalb fängt das
video langsam an das problem ist dass
der bäckermeister so schnell gesprochen
hat und auch mit china dialekt dass wir
eigentlich nicht doch weitermachen
konnten wir super easy german deshalb
haben wir dann einfach normal gesprochen
also jetzt ist es einfach mischmasch tut
mir leid
rainbow kognitive schreibt liebe kari
kari falsch beschrieben mit k wenn du
vivier zur deutsch lernenden zeigt
sollst du bestimmt besser vorbereiten
und für deutschland nur auf deutsch
sprechen alles gute hallo rainbow
kubicki ich weiß nicht ob du meinst aber
also ich nur auf deutsch sprechen tue
ich ja also wahrscheinlich einzig die
fragen die auf englisch kommen auch auf
deutsch vor lesen aber ich lese die
heiße vorgekommen weil warum auch nicht
und wenn du vielleicht meinst es sich
zwischendurch englische wörter benutzt
heute jemand anders
darüber haben wir schon erste
beschwerden bekommen aber das ist so
also man muss auch sprach und so nehmen
wie sie ist und sprache ist beweglich
und flexibel und die veränderlich und
was ist so dass wir im deutschen
englische wörter benutzen wie in ganz
vielen sprachen in vielen sparten
übrigens noch viel mehr hätte deutscher
englisch ist halt so wahl und wir
benutzen alle englisch irgendwann nie
teil jahre schreibt hallo karin janisch
ist der holocaust ein tabuthema in
deutschland auf meine erfahrung die
deutschen wollen daran denkt nicht
denken ohne sprechen
auf diese frage kann ich mir sagen nein
also ist es kein tabuthema in dem sinne
dass man das nicht ansprechen darf ich
glaube dass viele deutsche da viel
darüber lernen und auch darüber sprechen
wollen das ist gar keine frage aber es
ist natürlich trotzdem ein unangenehmes
thema also das ist ja so wenn wir jetzt
in deiner familie in wie ein opa
irgendwen ermordet hat da ist das jetzt
auch nicht das thema was man jetzt gerne
jeden abend bespricht na also es ist
schon schwieriges thema aber ich glaube
dass die deutschen sich ziemlich bewusst
darüber sind und sich sehr
wenn sich damit auseinandergesetzt haben
und auch auf jeden fall darüber sprechen
also wenn du das anspricht so jemanden
werden die kein problem damit haben und
werden die auch bestimmt alle alles
beantworten dazu aber natürlich werden
sie das jetzt nicht wenn man in der
nette zeit miteinander verbringt ist das
nicht das erste thema was man jetzt
gerade auf den tisch bringen das ist ja
wahrscheinlich verstehen
donald duck schreibt swatch typical
german ich kann super tanzen ja donald
das freut uns dann wird sein macht doch
ein video für uns schick uns das mal
hast du das noch was in meinem video mir
wie du tanzt unbedingt francis françois
poncet von weg schreibt deutsche menge
männer stecken immer das hemd in die
hose sogar t-shirts auch stimmt und über
polnische männer machen dass auch ja
nicht was auch ich mache mich immer
darüber lustig stimmt nicht das zeigt
wir so wir haben vorerst doch auch so
und zwar wenn du weil er sich anziehst
hinterausgang raus
als beweis zeigt er jetzt was er gerade
beineke auf und ich soll das jetzt
wahrscheinlich und video davon machen
also nach hinten video dianas dein hemd
zeigt thoma das ist ja na hat bei alba
das hemd hoch da drunter alten t shirt
in der hose jetzt soll das heraus also
vom fahr du hast recht du hast etwas
beobachtet was typisch deutsch ist was
noch niemand vor dir aufgefallen ist
jean-francois lhl schreibt wir haben das
beste brot der welt da berlin nur ein
paar stunden mit dem zug von der grenze
frankreich entfernt ist meinst du
genau so und zwar genau
lebenswirklichkeit hier genauso habe ich
mir norweger nach vorgestellt leute
genauso noch einmal ganz klar geht das
nicht ich muss jetzt muss schnell ein
foto machen
hammer zu unserem video web pickel
german schreibt 42 feindlich wheel of
soul session toilet bowl balls to
prevent the clash of the water authority
in der teufel bohley absolutely haybäck
places ja wer von euch bringt das noch
schreibt uns in die kommentare
danke für diesen kommentar wir sind
immer noch in einem fjord in norwegen
und die nächste frage
und der nächste konter kommt vom martina
bulgaria war die er übrigens aus
bulgarien kommt also sie schreibt die
parasiten wörter die deutschen immer
wieder holen geht nicht dass du nicht du
musst socken mit vandalen stimmt mit dem
tanzen stimmt auch bürokratie auch mit
schon zu hause lassen die neue wachen
oder unbekanntes essen nicht probieren
es ist immer katastrophe wenn es schneit
und die deutschen fahren müssen
die fahren einfach nicht und stehen
bleiben auf der straße im auto fahren
wir gerne hin
es ist auch diebe stolz auf die chance
warten obwohl es keine schlange gibt und
das beste brot in bulgarien
offensichtlich was du noch nicht da das
stimmt ich war noch nie in bulgarien
aber ich bin gerade mobbing
[Musik]
wir sind immer noch in einem fjord in
norwegen und unsere nächste frage ist
von maric 800 m als eine aussage zu
ihren song bei kraftwerk sums up the
germans in germany und zwar wir sind die
roboter mit sehr gut gefallen der
kommentar erwartet schreibt germanwatch
am nordturm ideen wärmen
das fenster war als mir das aufgefallen
ist dass wir ziemlich stolz zu sein
davon nicht typisch deutet habe ich
selber auch damit aufgehört zu sagen
dass ich ziemlich deutschland weil genau
das will ich nicht sagen ich will ja
nicht ziemlich stolz sein und wenn es
typisch deutsch ist dass man sagt man es
nicht besteuert dann will man natürlich
dass nicht weiterhin sagen dass man
typisch deutsche zwei bands wäre man
dazu besteht also habe ich natürlich
damit aufgehört
danke nochmal für den kommentar lilianas
da unten im spiegel dass furnish immer
besser also perez typisch deutsch leute
die in einem supermarkt vom ende der
schlange an eine neu öffnen der kasse
denn während nicht wären nicht
eigentlich wie die vorne schon länger
anstehen erst mal ran
ich komme aus spanien und habe das nur
in deutschland gesehen wo ist denn die
typisch deutsche ordnung hahaha
also ja nur das ist es auch vertretbar
und die ist kriterien also erst wenige
der herr anders die kaserne hat sich
geweigert ihn anzunehmen
du hast recht das ist typisch deutsch
ist also ordnung zu bewahren aber auch
natürlich ziemlich deutsch immer der
erste sein zu wollen deswegen in diesem
fall gläschen diese beiden dinge viel
sein werk am so genannten web it rock
drei kisten und dieses ding das 600
meter aus dem wasser heraus und ist eine
der bekanntesten wahrzeichen neuerdings
weil ich mir habe sagen lassen
bekannt ist er schreibt bücher warum
der grund dafür ist dass uns susanne
eine deutschlehrerin nach norwegen
eingeladen hat einige schulen zu
besuchen sie unterrichtet mich
deutschland einigen schulen und das
können wir nur in hin nach auge sondern
auch insel röwer sonne freuen uns
wahnsinnig rauchen wie ihr werdet dann
auf einige videos ein aus unserem
workshop v leute das war's und mit
unserem video heute
wir haben wieder auf fragen beantwortet
wie ihr seht ist es immer noch
wunderschön in norwegen und wir werden
noch ein paar tage hier bleiben wir
werden schon gebrochen wir werden video
zu drehen
seid ihr gespannt kopf rein auf unseren
kanaren kurz was es neues gibt und
schreibt irgend ein paar fragen also wir
freuen uns auf eure neuen fragen
wir wissen im moment kommt carly
antwortet nicht so regelmäßig wie ihr
euch das gerne wünscht und wie wir uns
das gerne wünschen aber wir möchten
jetzt öfter machen und wir versuchen es
immer wenn wir unterwegs sind machen wir
neue videos schreibt uns eure fragen zur
deutschen sprache und kultur konzerte
gerne in peshawar freuen uns über jeden
wirklich jeden ernst unterstützt werden
kontakt zu vielen von euch eine tolle
facebook gruppe und das ist einfach ein
wahnsinnig tolles support das könnt ihr
hier werden könnte patchen werden
danke bis zum nächsten mal schickt uns
mehr fragen